So I would like to now
consider the wheel that
is rolling without slipping.
And what I'd like
to do is consider--
let's draw the wheel
rolling without slipping.
And I'd like to consider the
contact point between the wheel
and the ground.
And I'd like to understand what
the velocity of that contact
point is.
And the result is surprising.
Now, we know by our law of
the addition of velocities--
let's call that the point P--
that the velocity of P is the
velocity of the center of mass,
and that pointed this way,
plus the velocity of the point
P as seen in the
center of mass frame.
And in that frame, every
single point on the rim
was just doing circular motion.
So that velocity is in
the opposite direction.
And the vector sum is the
velocity of this point P
as seen in the ground frame.
So we want to consider the
magnitudes of these two terms.
The velocity in the
center of mass frame
of a point on the rim has a
magnitude equal to r omega.
And we said that the velocity
of the center of mass,
we call that V cm.
Now, the rolling without
slipping condition
was that these two
magnitudes were equal.
V cm equals r omega,
or the velocity
of the point on the rim in
the center of mass frame
is equal to the center of
mass velocity of the wheel.
And therefore, the
velocity P, which
is the sum of these two
vectors for the contact point--
so that's when P is in
contact with the ground--
is equal to 0.
So what we say is
that the contact point
is instantaneously at rest
with respect to the ground.
And that's what really is
the mystery of a wheel that's
rolling without slipping--
that this contact point is
the sum of these two
vectors, and it's
instantaneously at
rest with the ground
when the wheel is
rolling without slipping.
The other points
are certainly not.
Remember, up here, these
two vectors pointed
in the same direction, so that
vector has twice the magnitude
of either one.